[Music]
there was an explosion and your legs the
gone bro how important was it for both
of you to show the real struggle and
blood sweat tears even vomit I think
that was probably the most important
thing for me so I have a lot of people
that hey you're going Hollywood to me
and like joking about it but I think
when they when they finally see the
movie they're gonna take over it I mean
I think the idea that someone's thrust
into the limelight in the midst of them
just trying to recalibrate their own
life but this movie is really about the
moments after that talking to you what
are you doing dancing you know there's
sometimes tragedies of mind for
entertainment and her movies but because
it's Jeff's experience was that
something that you got straight from
reading the script the first time you
know you can connect with Jeff you can
relate to him yeah you feel his pain you
feel his his strength
and and you can feel find it in yourself
then because of it I can't do this I
can't I can't I can't do it this is the
first time you're in this week and you
had three appointments you just have to
show us not all heroes wear capes right
yeah oh you like to work I'm gonna walk
with you in Sunday
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you